et on retrouve tout de suite le divine
sagnier et chiara mastroianni bonsoir à
toutes les deux en fait alors votre film
les chansons d'amour on vient de le voir
est une comédie musicale
c'est un vieux rêve d'enfant ce film
chanté ou pas du tout allez-y moi je
sais que j'ai toujours aimé chanter
j'avais déjà chanté dans des films et et
voilà le plaisir se prolonger fait super
faire un jour une comédie musicale et
j'étais ravi parce que j'adore ça
pourtant car à me soigner on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser à votre mère bien
évidemment dans les parapluies de
cherbourg palme d'or en 1964 de jacques
demy c'était un film important pour vous
celui ci oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est une
formidable aventure parce que c'est un
film que nous avons fait très vite qu'on
a fini de tourner il me semble fin
février où il y à peine 3 donc c'est
étonnant parce que c'est vrai que
d'habitude il ya quand même un certain
temps qui s'écoule et puis d'un coup le
film se termine on va à cannes enfin
tout semble très magique donc on profite
de cet instant et on voit là on se dit
qu'on a beaucoup de chance d'être là
alors j'ai pas encore vu ce film et ce
qui ressemble à ceux de jacques demy
justement ludivine vous en parlera mieux
que moi parce que je ne vais pas vu non
plus je vais le découvrir tout à l'heure
écoutez moi et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement quelques références que
tous les gens qui aiment le cinéma de
jacques demy pourront percevoir
maintenant c'est pas un film qui à la
manière 2 c'est un film qui est très
très contemporain je pense que
christophe honoré est ainsi né at
suffisamment brillant pour s'apparenter
à aucun autre
moi j'aime ce film parce que parce que
c'est une emma doré et que c'est un
cinéma qui est contemporain qui est
universel qui est réjouissant et qui est
authentique
est-ce que les chansons d'amour vous a
demandé un travail particulier
véritablement ou le disiez vous avez
déjà chanté dans 8 femmes je crois oui
oui ben c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu
quelques chansons enregistrées en studio
et et c'est un travail qui est assez qui
est assez original pour les acteurs
parce que c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
toujours l'occasion de chanter mais il
sait un côté très récréatif finalement
parce que bon on est obligé de se mettre
à nu tout de suite de chanter les uns
avec les autres donc c'est quand même
beaucoup de plaisir vous allez faire un
tour vous allez faire un album tout les
deux bientôt oui non pas ce serait bien
moi j'adore la façon de chanter de
ludivine de louis de clotilde aussi sont
ils ont des voix formidables et ludivine
j'avais déjà entendu chanter évidemment
non dans 8 femmes mais c'était très
c'était super de commencer comme ça
parce qu'en fait nous avons enregistré
les chansons avant de démarrer le film
et ensuite on avait on a eu un petit
mois qui s'est écoulée on avait les
disques de toutes les chansons du film
chacun de nous et donc on a plus on voit
là on se découvrait un petit peu à
travers ce disque là et c'est vrai que
quand le film a commencé il y avait déjà
quelque chose de très familier en fait
grâce à cette démarche de christophe et
et voilà c'était très ludique on n y
avait une bien sûr un petit peu
d'appréhension mais en même temps
christophe et
très léger par rapport à ça il a
beaucoup d'être à dédramatiser les
choses afin que notre angoisse s'apaise
et je dois dire que c'était c'était
réjouissant de travailler dans ces
conditions là de faire les choses de
façon très ludique
en tout cas on croise les doigts pour
vous pour la montée des marches et pour
la projection ce soir de ce film
français en compétition merci beaucoup
bonne soirée
le 23 mai merci au revoir merci à toutes
les deux